[music] boo hoo woo do
[music]
me
um yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[music]
Uzun
me
[music]
mushu
is my mother
[music
] was
] doing
erotic
[music]
yeah yeah yeah voodoo [music] n goo [music] 4 goo [music] ah ah ah
me not
me n
keyboard
[music]
[applause]
[music  ]
web
[music]
me
don't touch wh
I had
20 minutes hm
[applause]
[music]
t
nice yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah ani
b
7  a
ana no
[music]
paddy power meter
bl
[music]
[music] was
it
increased 6
tee
[music]
n
yeah yeah yeah [music] dht ji [music] yeah yeah yeah
can you do
b
[music]
no
p 4
mar
bejean
[music]
[applause]
re kind
web
no
bl
[music]
dea
tee
[applause]
[music]
web
wall e
[music]
[applause]
[ __ ]
[music]
yeah yeah yeah
web
def
n have
[music]
paddy te bl
patty b
[music]
pou
dou  dou
[music]
voodoo
b
[music]
b chief
[applause]
me
[music]
bip b
yeah yeah yeah
me
[music]
j
housewife
yeah yeah yeah
[music]
dea
dj
me
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
a3
tan
[music]
tee
[applause]
[music]
yeah yeah
me
re
car
goo
[music
] was in
vol 1
[music]
r 5
[music] go
a 2022  The
title of the new xbox title encourages me and makes me
rustle.Both hearts are full of expectations.It's
Mach rank, so please watch the video of
a child.It's nice to meet you, Nishi Rakugo storyteller
.
the backs The stream is about to begin
Well, we will deliver information about China this time as well
, so please enjoy it.
spouse Imen Green
Speepo terras trp arts and crafts pou
dou dou
as for a power to do
[music]
rear derailleur
tx pax mission this
for watch bring
tokoro menda p people
talend Wysfire 2 trop port
part
emet ppr min wedding
pauline  ppap doe
[music]
no 4 sapr 2 phase dare
to
do my play f
this
carefree rjp nag dx
pack mudie nb 4
1 cloud bridge pin 4 every also &
watchers a 5 af
x parts pro gaming match
player game el  way plaid
ren device means
points are you do
coming home play9 the
new impression
worth king mad making
pad game for a re  poor
place to wear way
destination to
do for
argb cars phaser rebun
to do
pas neighborhood greek audi
game + big zam the green green fun
con
4p coara newtype sx pocky
game to do
another jet bag jeng girl wee
arboarding game in counter
power amp the next for
needs to
with a t you making
x fax the best darwingie
weber and re make sure
game rba vo how have
good warpway
super s ear to do
h 2 do a
nabona tx 4 xe bush
agway gameshow debating
thank you  I hope
you enjoy I
'll take your heart from now on
[Music]
show time ep
me
yeah yeah
Shut up Miyazu rar
My persona
I'm a prepper I should be a
privacy Heal me  I don't know what it is, but it's
someone I've met
[music]
tan
nore 4 ni
Wait a minute, hey yeah
goo
Aizu beat
ni
I'm not standing anymore It
's okay I've got a cold
Number of
good points
Health, etc. 5 Zaroge - Released on October 21 When was Fu wa
Ore type e?
I myself loved the story of the girls of
the Three Kingdoms, so I set the stage in the turbulent times of the Three Kingdoms
and began to consider the concept of escape.
In addition to the overwhelming scale of the map
, we decided that the tempo centered on the five Chinese techniques and the
pom-bat of the kakeki could be a
concept for a new title, so we
started production of the rant.
A unique world view
makes it easy to imagine powerful enemies and harsh environments, and to
give you a sense of accomplishment when you overcome them.
Also, the world of the Three Kingdoms is an era of turmoil that is rare even in world history,
and I wanted to depict it head-on
.
team ninja's unique
directing method and approach
depicts a dark world
view.The battles of this work are also characterized by Chinese martial arts and poetry, and the
speedy action
unfolds in a flow where offense and defense are
exchanged.
We're aiming for a sense
of coexistence of tension and
exhilaration, where you win
side-by-side battles with spectacular action.  Feelings
are especially important. With
Galactor Plates, players
can play with the
look they want, which makes it even more immersive, and especially in
titles
like Outbound, playing so that your favorite character doesn't die is one of the
biggest motivations.
Also, even in online play, etc., there
will be large variations in stir-fry between players,
so I think the quality of the original play will depend on the pre-play.
Since it is a thing, there are fewer restrictions
on the
situation and
soberness of the main character, and by depicting the relationships with various warlords that appear in the Romance of the Three Kingdoms,
scenes in which the main character plays an active role in spectacular scenes are
opened.
I think it's an advantage that it's easy to draw. I think it
's not the difficulty itself that makes it popular, but that the
sense of accomplishment you get when you overcome a difficulty is an
emotion that you can't easily experience in
other genres or games.  I feel
that if the game is not unreasonable, has a high degree of freedom, and is straightforward, it will be a unique
experience that many
players will like.
We are promoting policies so that people can have experiences and sense of accomplishment that they have never had before
.
At the tgs venue, you'll be able to enjoy waist-based playstyles with different weapons and tactics,
so
please try
to find
a playstyle that suits you.  I think the key to your strategy is how to
raise your check. Whether you
dare to challenge a formidable enemy in order to make a big deal
, or you take it steadily,
how you control the battlefield is
the key to your strategy
[music]
[  Applause]
[Music]
Thank you all for your patience tokyo game show 2002 Thank you very
much for watching the
xbox stream in the spring.  From
all of Japan's proud game developers, and from
the studio with the strengths of countries around the world, including Asia
.  There
is an open on the xbox stream,
so
if it's a craft game that enjoys survival,
we'll bring you the latest information, including a new map campaign from World and Nara or Grade Points
.
Battle action exoto Lime I
have not prepared the latest video this time Please take a
look
ni
# e 0
be you ni If there was a view
, please tune in on the first day
Please fill in bye bye No yellowing
4 s eye petit  Rose's father 4 central ib
favorite female chin open Otsu is not called in a suit
Xasso-san who partnered with shirring Attached
loading stay Singer boots are
really big 2 xi But already on the grounder
a
v zone
lovely thin follow can't
be expected
punyuu nx eye repair only
[music]
unique figure mark sports bar voodoo suma echidna psoc pt sub
outerwear papamo martial arts set
tomoure house yan
sound punishment note action scene
you too w
telefone to
do  Oh
[music]
tue
dela
released to
do Ohfuto Turn Senshi
Michi de Naru
adele b en face 4
cda
yeah yeah
yeah
I'll let you go noa here par I've
got a reason to lose
So ah 14 yes
Heisei is good I
have to be like that
There's no way I can go
0 Ise bar
At that time gooooo
me
only Shirako day
he
definitely put Leon Raiju
[music]
tee
yeah
[music]
teame
dea
[music]
aname
wh
[music]
furry sports 4 a
ni
me
ani
ah ah
ah ah ah
I'm
Nasu Today,
I'm going to give you some new information about the game that users have
been waiting for.  For those who
couldn't access MORE, by uploading the game,
you will be able to access it again.
It's finally available for distribution.It
's a content that people who are just starting to play cola and 3d6 can enjoy,
so please give it a try.
We have decided to support in-game text localization for traditional Chinese and Korean as well.
We hope you enjoyed the information we announced today.
Stay tuned for
the latest news in the future.  please
thank you
me n
5 mins
[music]
hello millie xbox nosai
zaza impre belte  r game car
jps 2 thunder carne coo de bijuu
[music]
fuel fortus
oar
reap
doan fun surf wear
cream pure
n cute check distress 3 way
asante beads na residence [ __ ]
you
do n no go
pearls av see a safe
john are seen success
orders to do
earth oi dare to
do sports pau & follow
voodoo pure
rpg sound of legend unreliable at
what happened voodoo jocrp doe
movie star
voodoo
so re in japa ran
breath doburot f parks du clone
what is yes today
toilet bowl
[  Music]
Yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
Pictures are important from now
on Can you save our world with a gadget,
me face?
I want to help my mother.
[music]
ah ah ah
re
[music]
me
ni
ano
ano ah ah ah
[music]
Boo Boo Osako no Shinsekai no Haha next week
Gakuen Nu
[Applause]
Pie back dai
ni
Stealing leagues and thorough guards will at least return to where they are
There's more than one entrance to the av room
.  And this is the final decision
It won't be that easy and
you
can do it
We won't give up
I
[Music]
I'm going my own way I
'll play
I'm running with a blade
[music]
me
Shina bamboo house is gone
bejean I'm
recovering
no
The
new character Kiriko will be unveiled to the public for the first time in the world
. Have you seen your partner Kisune-chan
?  Next
, I would like to introduce the long-awaited jr pc
100 Eiyuden. You can enjoy an
epic story woven by the characters
of the 100 Yen Show.  100
Eiyuden, a jrpg with such high expectations, can be played at the nuclear plant from the first day of its release.
[music]
[applause]
me
[music]
[applause]
I think there's something new and exciting about putting a prefectural title out into the world.
Personally, I think it's more important than anything else to want people to experience it, so as someone on the
creator's side,
I'm always doing my best to be able to bring
that out.
An ensemble drama unfolded by more than 100 heroes drawn by Ame-san, and a
variety of games such as battles that allow players to experience the ensemble drama and community development in a first-class war area
.
They're just a part
of the human
heroes.  In
Murayama-san's ensemble drama,
characters from various positions appear, and
each of them acts in their own position
, intertwining them to create a story.
Two leaders in the room  In
novels and movies, characters that appear in one scene and then
end up
have various purposes and standpoints.
Because it's the real pleasure of the game to be able to guess
the character.It's hard to make when there are many, but right now I don't have a specific character
that I like.
I think that by
playing as a single player,
you will be
able to find a
character that you like.
But recently, I've been playing Rising,
so I've come to love cj and Lou.
I'm thinking about putting it out in a game.
Please look forward to it, including in what form it will come out.
But RPGs
take a lot of time to develop, and things like this one with a
lot of
characters appearing take a lot of
time.I'm really sorry about that.
I have no choice but to say no, but if I have a message now,
please wait
just a little longer
.
fufufu
me
[music]
ana
uh
car
aname
[music]
me
good
[music]
ff
eme
[music]
ni
this journey absurd
piece
That's a dozen
3 minutes on
an epic, action-packed journey in Assassin's Creed Odyssey set in ancient Greece
Let's go out and support the operation
This work will appear at the nuclear power plant sooner or later Today
, we
still have a good continuation of our battle In
addition, we will help our friends who are trapped inside the god car
In the word contest, the
boys are waiting for a turn again Harsh management,
etc. The
truth hidden on the other side of the world
Unbearable pain and
the death of a loved one Meet the boy as a reviewer In the
depths,
absolutely never forgive
The [music] that kills you
doesn't know what lies ahead I
was free to
catch Kawaei
[music]
I feel like I've wasted my hard work
Put together the clues in the
24 hours,
8 people, pay
attention to the sidewalk Juliana's attack, I'll
clean it up today,
[ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah
[music]
me
yeah yeah yeah [music] I want to fly ah
oh oh me surprise w [music] that low head [music] what the hell oh oh oh
[music]
big dog
yeah yeah everything is going well today
my island my practice
A part of my brain when I was managing the system with your condition detouch surface
Hello everyone
wish ah finally blue
duster
this app is steller
2 ios
entendre version react
to do ag voodoo fish
tomorrow cornwiller love 3 story
the
voodoo 5  a jend s i clover ins 1 annoying as juliana instep
preserved starch 4 pine bd 4
a son omerta
[music]
voodoo pro 4 serious key
heaven network yukiyan star pearl disp i
none bully hope to
do in place stree
c  undress 5 days ibr
Thank you very much. I would like
to take this opportunity to
express my deep gratitude to all the game titles announced
today. Thank you very much for watching today.  There's still a long way to go at
Tokyo Game Show 2020. I hope
you'll continue to enjoy it.
]
[music]